guy's Thrones is back and two episodes
in I'm geeked and slightly confused does
anyone else find themselves saying what
the hell's that guy they introduced like
seven new characters per episode if you
need help keeping it all straight or
your friends will give you their HBO Go
password you're in the right Kingdom
screen junkies presents the idiots guide
to Game of Thrones
warning if you're not caught up on the
show spoilers ahead fat King Robert
Baratheon dying is what really got the
ball rolling
everybody wants his throne his son
Joffrey took the throne in the Seven
Kingdoms Oh Joffrey is like Justin
Bieber on bath salts that's what happens
when you're the product of incest yeah
his mom Searcy did it with her brother
Jamie like ah gross they're Lannisters
Lannisters suck except for one Tyrion
Lannister aka Peter Dinklage he rules
but he's like the Rodney Dangerfield of
Westeros very funny but he gets no
respect and he's got a messed-up face
Plus people hate on him cuz he's a dwarf
not cool guys so Joffrey really started
some [ __ ] when he beheaded Ned Stark end
of season one major WTF moment Ned was a
righteous dude now his son Robb Stark is
king of the north and is coming for
little Joffrey that is in between
marrying a nurse and putting his mom in
jail another stark boy is brand stark he
has a psychic link with his pet and his
legs don't work he rides on the back of
a very large man who talks like a
Pokemon hold on Hodor Hodor Hodor oh
don't get Jew bran and his forgettable
little brother are traveling with dirty
hair she is seriously building on
Parkins thank y'all
but see on Greyjoy boned her anyway he
was an honorary Stark who then pillaged
the Starks hometown of Winterfell and
now he's getting totally screwed what'd
you do get it cuz he's getting torture
with screw he cause none of her children
are safe mama Stark very sad so she sent
tilda swinton on steroids to bring sir
bangs his twin sister a lot back to the
Lannisters in hopes that they'll give up
her daughters she doesn't realize her
tomboy daughter Arya Stark is running
through the woods playing with swords
Arya Stark straight-up badass another
stark is Tony Stark
he's Iron Man and has nothing to do with
this except that he's as rich as Tywin
Lannister Joffrey's grandpa who saved
his ass in the Battle of Blackwater Bay
but he's totally a deadbeat dad
Dinklage and won't give him ownership of
Casterly Rock you
Casta LaRoque it is mine by right give
the dwarf the rock Margaery Tyrell super
baby knows how to use her cleavage to
manipulate a king going through puberty
plus she's got a gay brother and is
totally cool with it
do you want my brother to come in and
help but he could get you started I know
he wouldn't mind
thanks to her Jinger Stark is no longer
marriage material for King beaver and on
the other side of the ocean is the
Khaleesi the dragon mom Daenerys
Targaryen Wow my dragons she wants the
most uncomfortable seat in the world as
well and she's packing the most powerful
weapons in Fantasyland shakarez she used
to bang Conan
but now she's hanging with two knights
who have their AARP cards sir Barristan
Selmy was fired by that dirty little
incest King in season one yeah boy
melted down and added to the others yeah
that's who that guy is
surge or Marmont he's totally crushing
on Khaleesi it's kind of gross cuz he
could be your dad come on oh and surge
or Marmont he's actually the son of this
guy Lord Commander Mormont the leader of
the Nights Watch and everybody's
disappointed dad look at me
did you send the Ravens
he's racing magical zombies back to the
wall with Sam Sam's like the fat kid who
always got picked last for kickball Jon
Snow the coolest bastard north of the
wall he's literally the bastard son of
Ned Stark
he left the Nights Watch and he's
fighting alongside this guy Mance Rayder
who leads them all because he also
played Caesar in another HBO show then
there's this guy fat dead King's brother
Stannis Baratheon his semen made a demon
he also believes himself to be the
rightful king and guys don't forget
there's tons of boobs
isn't that right Amy that's right
this shows awesome so was that helpful
what'd we leave out did you want us to
talk about hot pie more hot pie talk we
loved that chubby guy who's your
favorite game of Thrones character who's
the most annoying character who do you
hate the most
leave a comment in the comment section
below telling us who and why best answer
gets a screen junkies t-shirt thank you
for watching I'm howl running Mike